arrested by his own colleagues
this is pc benjamin hannah i've called
to just point them out don't touch them
if you can try and avoid yeah yeah it's
fun no it's fine it's just
it's just that phone this apple watch
and my old pc tower down there
okay but i don't even have a monitor you
can see
yeah i haven't used that since you know
it's march last year the young officer
has been arrested for
involvement in far-right extremism
when officers searched his electronic
devices
they found this picture of pc hannah in
uniform
with a superimposed hitler moustache and
nazi emblem
he claimed a former school friend had
done it as a joke
police also found this self-declared
manifesto
by the far right terrorist anders
breivik who murdered
77 people mostly teenagers in a gun and
bomb attack in norway
in 2011. elsewhere around his bedroom in
north london
were nazi propaganda posters and a diary
which detailed him joining the now
banned far right
group national action
[Music]
the home secretary outlawed that group
in 2016
as part of a drive against far-right
terrorist activity
the 22-year-old continued meeting with
members of the group
despite that ban here in the white
t-shirt
he's taking part in a physical fitness
session and boxing match in woodland
with those group members no hesitation
getting there first get him first
adam continued to meet with the group
and formed an offshoot
organisation just weeks before applying
to join the met
police
there are questions for the mets vetting
process
which failed to seek references from his
school
where teachers had expressed concerns
about his extremist views in class
this is a unique case this is the first
time a police officer has been
prosecuted for an offence of this nature
it was a shock to the investigative team
it will be a shock to the public too but
i hope the public will be reassured at
how fast we moved
to arrest and prosecute ben hannam for
his previous membership of national
action
the young officer and his fellow
extremists called their offshoot group
ns131 here he's spray-painting the
group's logo
on a structure in swindon the group
videoed and photographed themselves
spraying their logos and holding an
extremist flag
for a propaganda video scotland yard
carried out an urgent review
of pc hannah's arrests and his stop and
search activity
the force said it found no evidence that
any of his on-duty behavior
had been influenced by his far right
extremist beliefs
mark white sky news